[Music]
speaking of data dave uh we saw job
numbers from june come out the economy
added 372 000 more jobs so we're still
waiting to see are we in a recession are
we not but people need to relax because
even if we see the gdp
uh slow into where we are in a recession
we are still seeing a very hot job
market well i would have been wrong then
if because i predict i predict a
recession a light one yeah but i think
the economy is going to shrink two
quarters in a row and shrinking two
quarters in a row is a recession it's
not the end of the world and we might
see just a slowing down of that's the
craziness i mean because people came out
of their caves after covid you know like
a baptist after a casserole i mean they
bought everything in
sight they started buying stuff
hand-over-fisting and the factories
hadn't been making nothing and so the
prices went up on everything it drove
inflation crazy
and you can blame joe biden but it's not
all his fault part of it's his fault but
it's you know it's not i mean if you
watch fox news though everything's his
fault but um
but the uh if you watch cnn nothing's
his fault and they're still talking
about trump
that's all they talk about but but
bottom line is it's trump's fault yeah
that's whose fault it is i don't know
how but it is probably reagan's fault
actually but
clinton that's who we should blame sure
but um but yeah and the truth is none of
them have as much control as everybody
like think they do but they can do some
stupid stuff like cut off the gas supply
and drive grass prices oh sure that one
was stupid but um but the the a lot of
this other inflation stuff is coveted
based that's because of demand yeah and
so that's driving this job market thing
man i'm telling you i you know we we
took some time off for our 40th
anniversary last week
and you know uh we're in a resort
setting beautiful area they're having
trouble getting people to work that's
correct still but still a labor shortage
we're still seeing more jobs created the
pandemics spun off a lot of new jobs and
a lot of people went on their own that's
true a lot of entrepreneurs and so again
here's the point what we're going to see
in the real estate reality check the
live stream you're going to see really
good data you're going to see
encouragement in in a major part of this
economy and that's real estate and i'm
telling you in the job part of things we
are still in a historic
job economy we are at 3.6
unemployment that is the same number
that we were in february of 2020 this is
right before everybody went home for a
season when the pandemic hit in march
and the economy was quite hot then and
it was and so we saw a lot of people
lose their jobs and just to give people
perspective here uh we're seeing now the
unemployment rate back down to
pre-pandemic levels so this guy did you
see that coming i thought i thought
employment was going to cool off
uh well two things i did see i did see
that we would come out of this pandemic
where we had a lot of people i mean in
the last in the last 90 days i thought
it was going to come down
yes because we did see a lot of layoffs
in in may it was reported big time
companies you know that was the pre you
know the pre uh condition for the
research second quarter that's right
leading into the recession and and this
indicates i might be wrong that there
might not be a recession well because
companies don't hire big time in a
recession they do not and so i think
you're going to see parts of the economy
will we might technically see a
recession i'm studying a lot of
economists right now they're still
waiting to see i think your prediction
is going to be right i think we'll see
an actual small recession of the gdp but
that can be true at the same time we see
companies laying people off we saw big
tech lay a bunch of people off in may as
a reaction to
uh a slowdown in consumer spending
amazon announced layoffs really yes uh
yeah in the last two weeks but that's
because inflation fears are naturally
bringing people the everyday consumer
the american family that we talk to day
in and day out they are spending less we
rc consumer spending drop but
it doesn't mean that you'll see layoffs
happen in a healthy economy and you'll
see people add jobs so what we're seeing
now dave is a little bit of a reset and
a return to a normal job economy where
some companies and industries will lay
off
others will increase so for instance i
think you're going to see in the
construction and manufacturing spaces a
lot of jobs added and we saw that in the
june job report because now things are
starting to heat up again well that's
encouraging because that's various
people who make things yeah and see
you're going to share this i'm sure in
the real estate reality check event
we've been talking about but a healthy
uh construction and housing start
economy is always good when we see good
things there we see good economic
indicators so i just think to your point
let's focus on the facts and not the
headlines that are designed to get you
to click on them designed to get you to
snap your neck in the living room and
keep watching so
if the uh jobs report came in that
positive yeah
um in fact the only area that contracted
dave were government jobs oh darn i knew
you'd appreciate killing me here i knew
you'd appreciate it to which we all said
thank you lord but yeah
and the congregation said amen but the
uh all right so
hmm
because the great resignation was both
an accident existential thing where
people got the crap scared out of them
i'm gonna die someday so i'm not gonna
work a job i hate yes so i'm gonna quit
this job and go do something else that's
that was an element of it but another
element of it was there was such a
shortage of labor they could go they
could anywhere they wanted to go and do
anything they wanted to do
and also spurred up this uh home home
school on a homeschool work from home
stuff that's right and uh that
you know people are tolerating anything
just to hire people that's correct in
terms of you work wherever you want just
help me i need some help and that kind
of thing and uh
some wonder i was wondering i kind of
had the hope that that was all cooling
off but if this job report's heating up
then that stuff may still rock on for a
while
we may be sitting in that all summer
you're going to see the great
resignation the job hockey continue
because we saw may's numbers 392 000
jobs were added june 372. so you're
looking at uh you know almost 800 000
jobs in the last two months
things aren't as bad as the news would
believe lead you to believe yeah there
it is